abgeschnitten von der außenwelt ist die
heilig blut ein unzugängliches eiland
einige stunden später bei apple lädt das
wattenmeer zur erkundung ein somit für
eine wanderung durch den küstenstreifen
der nordsee dessen antlitz durch die
gezeiten geprägt ist
mit einem erfahrenen wattführer geht es
zur hallig norderoog keine zehn hektar
misst die heilig ein ungewohnter flecken
erde sieht man vom aufenthalt des vogels
ab und den zigtausend sie vögeln die
hier rasten oder brüten das wattenmeer
der nordsee ist ein einzigartiges
ökosystem mit millionen von krebsen
muscheln und sie sternen
bei einer wanderung macht man in jedem
fall bekanntschaft mit einem typischen
nordsee bewohner der wattwurm frist sand
nimmt dabei die organischen stoffe auf
und stößt dann den samt wieder aus ein
lebensstil den wattführer bei boysen auf
den grund geht der wattwurm den land bis
zu 30 zentimeter tief runterspülen kann
über diese röhre und nachher auch über
seinen magen und darm trakt rechnet man
ganz grob im schnitt fährt ein einzelner
faktor 20 kilo sand einmal im jahr durch
wer noch mehr über das wattenmeer und
seine bewohner wissen möchte der sollte
nach tönning fahren
hier befindet sich das wort forum
die besucher erfahren zum beispiel warum
das wattenmeer weltnaturerbe der unesco
wurde ein titel für den christiane gelte
und ihre kollegen mit ausdauer kämpften
und haben das dann ja auch ein paar tage
später groß an leuchtturm westerhever
auch mit leuten aus der region gefeiert
das war 2009 die nordsee bewohner die
man hier in wattforum beobachten kann
profitieren davon
der titel weltnaturerbe soll zum schutz
des nationalparks wattenmeer beitragen
dass dieser schutz notwendig ist auch
darauf wird der besucher aufmerksam
gemacht schließlich bedrohen
überfischung und globale erwärmung das
ökosystem die biologische vielfalt ist
gefährdet
und die ist immerhin ein ausgewiesenes
merkmal für das wattenmeer als
weltnaturerbe
genauso übrigens wie die geologische
beschaffenheit geschichtlicher sicht
sehr jung nur zehn bis zwölftausend
jahre alt und hat sich eben in der zeit
in der letzten eiszeit gebildet da ist
es entstanden
aber es verändert sich seitdem ständig
weiter und zwar täglich
die gezeigten folge gibt den takt für
die besucher vor
zb wenn man auf die insel juist fährt
die ostfriesische insel ist nur bei flut
mit dem schiff erreichbar
das lahmende festland ist auf einmal
weit weg statt autos fahren hier pferde
kutschen vor gut 600 jahren wurde die
insel erstmals urkundlich erwähnt heute
leben hier 2001 wohnung
die zahlreichen besucher haben viel
platz vor allem auf den breiten weißen
strand
hier mit der kutsche unterwegs sein
dem wattenmeer lauschen und den wechsel
der gezeiten beobachten
auch so kann man das welterbe wattenmeer
erleben